[Music]
during the second world war nazi germany
made enemies of europe and much of the
world
but the regime had another lesser-known
foe the rising threat from a deadly
disease
dana jacobson traveled to philadelphia
to speak with author sam
apple who uncovered a fascinating
connection between the nazis
a jewish scientist and a breakthrough
cancer research
that's still being studied today cancer
had really become a german obsession by
the 1920s
it was almost a panic and i think that's
in large part because the disease had
become so much more common
by the 1930s cancer was the second
leading cause of death in germany
and a grave concern for the country's
ruling party
the nazis nobody understood why it was
happening i mean to this day we don't
fully understand and that's a lot of
what my book is about that book
by author sam apple is titled ravenous
otto warburg the nazis and the search
for the cancer diet connection
take me back then and introduce me to
otto
warburg who was he sure otto warburg
was a brilliant german scientist he was
born in the late 19th century
and his father was a famous jewish
physicist emil warburg
einstein and max planck and fritz haber
and emil
fisher all these world famous scientists
are in warburg's house when he's growing
up
and warburg idolizes these men and and
decides that
you know he's going to be a great
scientist too and that's what
warburg did in 1931 he was awarded the
nobel prize for his research on cellular
respiration
his discovery that cancer cells take up
nutrients and eat in a different way
from
other cells became known as the warburg
effect
technically what the warburg effect is
that it was understood
that a human cell could turn to
fermentation
but it was thought that's something that
a cell only does in desperation that's
something that a cell does when it
doesn't have oxygen and actually
if you exercise really intensely and you
start breathing and your lungs are heavy
you know you don't have enough oxygen to
sort of run respiration so your cells do
turn
to fermentation that's but the warburg
effect is really he discovered that
cancer cells were doing this even though
you know there was oxygen available
warburg continued his research as the
nazis strengthened their grip on germany
he refused to leave his homeland even
though he was jewish
and gay living openly with his male
partner
he said i was here before hitler who's
going to tell me to get out of my
institute he had this gorgeous institute
that had built for him two years earlier
but it's built with money from the
rockefeller foundation and he said
they can't touch me as others attempted
to appease the nazis
warburg provoked them so these nazi
brown shirts would come to his institute
and harass him and at one point he said
you know i'm going to burn down my
institute if you come here again how
dare you show up here
you refused to give the nazi salute you
refused to put up the nazi flags that
all the other institutes were doing
how did he survive and not get sent to a
concentration camp as other jews or
homosexuals would have been yeah
and so it really comes to a head in 1941
he knows he stayed too long he knows he
should have left and
they call him into hitler's chance
theory this is
like the truly the belly of the beast
you know they tell him we're going to
let you live
but you're going to focus on cancer
apple says the timing of the meeting
shows just how
serious the nazis were in their
offensive on the disease
it was hours before operation barbarossa
started
this was the biggest moment in the nazi
project they were going to invade the
soviet union
hours and this is what they're talking
about hours before cancer research in
warburg
in his own research apple uncovered
another surprise
hitler's obsession with cancer was
personal
historians say that his mother was the
only person he loved the only person he
had a relationship with
and she died of breast cancer how did
did that manifest itself later on with
the nazi party
cancer was one more impurity and the
jews were one more impurity for hitler
and the nazis so
in a way it fits into this dark sort of
outlook that they had was that hard when
you're writing about that to wrap your
head around
some of it yeah it it was very hard
like most jews i you know lost family
members and the holocaust and
anytime you're researching these things
it's difficult
but it also deeply uncomfortable to i'm
so
repulsed by the nazis to the core of my
being to say that they made
any sort of progress in cancer yeah i
hate saying that
six million jews were persecuted and
murdered by the nazi regime
and its allies and collaborators warburg
would survive the war leaving many in
the scientific community
to wonder how before the war you know it
had been a major
ideas about cancer that it involves this
metabolic shift
and then after the war i'd say in the
1950s it's still around but it starts to
to sort of fade away and there's a bunch
of different reasons for that but one of
the
kind of shocking ones is that people
suspected warburg for having stayed in
nazi germany
how did this guy survive did he
collaborate one of the samples by the
mid-70s warburg's metabolic approach was
all but forgotten as
scientists discovered cancer-causing
genes or oncogenes so everyone was now
focusing on oncogenes and what do they
do
and it's taken us a long time to figure
out what they do now we know what they
do
is they pretty much alter metabolism
and so which brings you back to brings
back to otter warburg right
dr louis cantley is the director of the
meyer cancer center at weill cornell
he discovered a previously unknown
enzyme
pi3k we're heading into the tissue
culture room
so these are the incubators where we
grow the cancer cells
sam apple approached dr cantley while
researching his book to ask a critical
question
could our diets be causing cancer i
think sugar is the most dangerous food
we eat
so when you consume fructose and it gets
to the liver gives you fatty liver
you become insulin resistant and that
means ambient insulin levels are high
all the time you know my lab discovered
that insulin
activates this enzyme pi3k
and the gene for that is one of the most
frequently mutated
genes in cancer and it's activated by
insulin so if your insulin resistant
and you pick up one of these mutations
you have a very good chance that that's
going to drive the growth of that tumor
author sam apple found that dr cantley
is just one of a number of scientists
concerned about
sugar and cancer my goal in writing
my book ravenous was really to see if
there's a way to connect these stories
to
to put warburg into the perspective of
the whole diet story
you know my research and talking to many
cancer scientists really
came down to sugar in a very fundamental
way modern theories
built on more than a century of science
actually been this tremendous metabolism
revival you know it started in in the
late 1990s and now they have conferences
and new
metabolism centers are opening and it's
really
fundamentally changed cancer science so
you know warburg was lost and
and now he he's been rediscovered a book
i did not know about beforehand but
we'll
but we'll check out now sounds
fascinating thank you dana remarkable
legacy too to think about
all of the conflict he must have felt
you know
working on this but at the same time
knowing he was working on the project he
wanted to advance the science
and advancing it yeah we're still
talking about it today so glad we
rediscovered this
this lost history for sure